bonjour katia leur fameux le dire les
accords ont été signés que peut-on
retenir de cette journée
oui absolument beaucoup d'effervescence
aujourd'hui à matignon parce que après
plusieurs semaines de négociations et
bien les accords sur la revalorisation
des personnels hospitaliers et ceux des
ehpad a été signé alors jean castex le
nouveau premier ministre estime qu'il
témoigne de la reconnaissance
considérable à l'égard de celles et ceux
qui étaient en première ligne
quant à olivier ferrand il a salué un
accord historique de par son ampleur en
effet il s'agit d'une enveloppe de 8,1
milliards d'euros
alors je vous propose d'écouter
justement ministre de la santé à propos
de ces augmentations socle un que
réclamer les personnels hospitaliers
depuis de très nombreux mois pour l'
écoute je sais la force de l'engagement
pour ces professionnels du quotidien et
donc être capable aujourd'hui d'être le
ministre qui permet à ce million et demi
de salariés d'avoir une augmentation ce
qu'il faut rentrer dans les chiffres
le 183 euros nets mensuels pour toute
personne qui travaille à l'hôpital
auquel s'ajoute un deuxième volet via un
travail sur les grilles indiciaires pour
que les métiers qui sont les plus en
tension notamment les infirmiers aides
soignants mais pas que puisse avoir
encore un gain équivalent 35 euros net
par mois
tout cela ce ne sont pas des primes tout
cela monsieur le premier ministre c'est
en bas à droite de la feuille de paye ça
compte dans la vie professionnelle
ça compte au moment de la retraite et
puis le troisième volet de la fusée de
cette revalorisation
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'engagement
collectif
l'engagement collectif c'est la capacité
qu'auront demain les équipes de
s'organiser au sein des hôpitaux pour
être capable de porter des projets
améliorant la qualité des soins pour les
malades
alors cet accord en particulier a été
signé par les syndicats trois syndicats
du cou qui sont devenus majoritaires la
cfdt fo unsa
pour autant cet accord de 7,5 milliards
d'euros donc évoqué le ministre de la
santé ne fait pas l'unanimité et le
second ne fait pas non plus l'unanimité
chez les syndicats de médecins que nous
avons subi ce matin il s'agit donc d'un
accord concernant les médecins
hospitaliers les syndicats qui n'ont pas
signé se plaignent du fait que les
gardes ne sont pas revalorisés les
heures supplémentaires non plus que le
salaire d'embauché déjà de médecins
n'est pas assez attractif et que la
revalorisation des salaires ne concerne
que la fin de carrière c'est pourquoi
les syndicats qui sont déçus de du
premier accord de 7,5 milliards d'euros
et ceux qui sont déçus également du
second accord vont se retrouver demain
dès demain pour manifester donc il y
aura les syndicats la cgt ira sud-santé
amuf les urgentistes ainsi que le snp
les infirmiers demain pour un parcours
de république à bastille ça c'est à
paris et ils manifesteront également
posé sur tout le territoire
katia merci pour toutes ces précisions